OK, so we're continuing our tour through the
delusions of Fox News today.
I have two Fox News religious clips and one
is an example of a religious leader being
responsible about Corona virus.
That's the first one.
The second Fox News Corona virus religious
clip is a religious nut being completely irresponsible
about Corona virus.
OK, so let's start.
Remember that Donald Trump at one point wanted
the country open by Easter and it's a sort
of God complex gone wrong.
I've talked about this before, Trump seeing
himself as a sort of Jesus like figure, resurrecting
the country on Easter, Easter, much like the
biblical Easter story of Jesus's resurrection.
Now, ultimately, it didn't work, would be
hugely dangerous to reopen the country this
Sunday.
That's when Easter is.
Imagine we're not even at the peak yet.
Trump was thinking about reopening, but there's
a lot of really big evangelical churches that
don't care.
They keep gathering huge crowds.
And Fox News host Laura Ingram really wants
religious gatherings to continue because otherwise,
as she says, nobody will gather to pray until
out.
Anthony Foushee says it's okay, which to me
makes sense, right?
I mean, like, don't we need doctors and not
pastors deciding when it's safe to gather
in huge groups?
So check out Laura Ingram on her show.
Truly vile.
While interviewing a Catholic priest, Father
Murray and then some other guy.
I don't know who the other guy is, but he
doesn't speak during this segment.
Check it out.
I think, Father Murray, a lot of people, especially
the working class people of our country, the
people who pay the bills, who don't get a
lot of accolades.
People that a lot of us came from there.
The what this is like the time where they
need a public affirmation of their faith.
It's all well and good to say.
Stay at home.
I heard some priest on TV might have even
been on our network saying, oh, it's the domestic
church.
And oh, yeah, I get that.
But it's this is this is holy week and.
And just to say, because the bishops say you
can't I don't know.
I'm I've got to say out blessing the palms,
public blessings, people far apart.
Otherwise, you know, maybe we won't have mass
until Anthony Foushee says it's OK after Christmas
or something.
I mean, I guess what, the bishops feel OK
with that?
I don't know the people who work.
They need to go to church.
And Laura Ingram seems incredulous that wait,
people are staying home during holy week.
How is this possible?
So there's Laura Ingram being insane.
But now we get to Father Murray's response.
Father Murray's response is absolutely correct.
Now there's two funny little things that you'll
notice in Father Murray's response.
One is that he refers to Corona virus as Kaura
no, no virus, which I just love.
It's an extraordinarily endearing.
And as he does it, his headphone also falls
out of his right ear.
So a lot of things visually going wrong for
Father Murray, but he is absolutely right
and doing the responsible thing.
And for that, he should be commended.
Take a look.
Father, I want to get in trouble to say this.
Not going to get me in trouble.
You say this 60 priest died in Italy.
One bishop.
And that was because they had the device without
knowing it.
And they put out, you know, that disease into
their congregation.
And so many people have died in Italy.
And, you know, we don't want to repeat that
here.
You have to get ahead of the curve.
You can't just keep things, you know, as they
were.
And it's regretful.
But, you know, whatever you do, the least
of my brethren, you do to me, if you sacrifice
going to mass, get sick.
I think that's a form of praising God.
So the Catholic priest pointing out essentially,
stay the hell home, actually saying the responsible
thing, you should stay home.
Priests have died in Italy.
This is not good.
Staying home to avoid being sick is good.
God's not going to be bad.
God's not going to punish you.
So good for Father Murray here.
He's doing absolutely the correct thing.
And unfortunately, on Fox News, we continue
to see every dangerous narrative that is being
parroted by Trump and people around him repeated
ad nauseum.
Chloroquine, chloroquine, chloroquine.
What do you have to lose?
Take it, take it, take it up.
We got to go to church.
Prayer is so important.
Keep tithing.
Keep donating to your church.
So good for Father Murray here for getting
involved and saying, no, that's the wrong
thing.
A responsible example of a religious leader
commenting on what has to be done about coronavirus.
Unfortunately, now we get to the irresponsible
one